last time on the OIC Diaries I am down a
total of 21 lbs after three doses which
is awesome I'm getting a little bit
obsessive over it not really obsessive
over what I'm doing but obsessive over
what can I do to speed up the process so
I don't know if there's like a
correlation between OIC and the rise of
anxiety or or depression or those sort
of manic behaviors uh and the mental
health issue so I just like to see
results right away hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to aby's
[Music]
Kitchen in today's video we'll be
catching up with my friend business
partner and manager ginger on her OIC
weight loss Journey now last month on my
channel I reviewed a handful of OIC what
aena day videos that have basically just
been circulating around online and I
gave my honest yet educated dietitian
thoughts and this week ginger has asked
me to do the same for her now a quick
disclaimer that this video will include
numbers calories and Extreme Weight Loss
discussion also please note that the
individual in the series is not my
actual client so any suggestions are for
general knowledge and education only
everyone's needs are unique and really
should be discussed oneon-one with your
healthcare provider now before we get
into it let's bring in Jinder and we can
catch up on some of her impressive
results and Journey so far but let's
talk about my New Year's resolutions
with my sponsor hungry root so I am all
about setting smart goals so instead of
lofty vague resolutions like lose 10 lb
I'm all about actionable steps that you
can take like having one meatless meal a
day or trying one new recipe every week
or switching up your weekly fruits and
veg and services like hungry root can
actually make it doable hungry root is
an online grocery service that makes
makes eating healthier easy and more
accessible you can fill out a quick quiz
and hungry will recommend fresh
groceries and simple 10-minute recipes
tailor to your goals preferences and
abilities you can edit your weekly
deliveries to choose exactly what you
want or you can let hungry root take the
guest workk out of it for you they can
tailor your order for gluten-free vegan
vegetarian and dairyfree and they offer
over 2,000 recipes so you will never get
bored honestly it's been a great way to
get out of the postol cooking red and to
save money time food waste and multiple
trips to the grocery store I love all
their different prepped veggie stir fry
mixes and the kids love their little
snack packs they are definitely making
lunch packing stressfree so if you want
to try out hungry root yourself the
first 100 people to use my code Abby 40
will get 40% off of their first order so
use the link in the description or scan
the QR code and use Abby 40 for 40% off
welcome Ginger so nice to see you hi ABY
good morning
everyone um let's do a quick little
recap here with some rapid fire
questions number one how many weeks now
have you been on OIC 33 weeks wow 33
weeks seems like a pregnancy that's like
I'm 33 weeks along yeah I know love that
except instead of gaining weight I'm
losing weight right right right exactly
um what dose are you on right now 2
milligram excellent um how much weight
have you lost so far the big question
yeah so I have lost 34 and2 lbs wow how
are you feeling about this that's huge I
feel really good it's funny I was
shopping yesterday and you know instead
of shopping for extra large I was
shopping for medium so like that was a
big I mean listen the numbers on clothes
as we know are just like fictional um
but it was very surreal to me to
actually like be trying on medium so
that was I haven't I haven't been there
in such a long time so that was was a
nice it was a nice feeling it just like
it's kind of like oh you see your body
every day in the mirror but the clothes
these new clothes are just seeing your
new body now right so right oh and so
tell me I mean I have to do the math
math is not my thing but how many
typically how much are you losing per
week just about a pound amazing and
that's exactly really where we want to
be because one of the big risks when it
comes to drugs like OIC is muscle loss
because of rapid weight loss so we
really want to stay in that sweet spot
of 1 to 2 pounds per week to help to
reduce that risk so that is a great
weight loss rate we love that okay so
any major side effects that we're
dealing with right now yeah so this new
one that I'm dealing with is hair loss
and I'm not sure if it's related to like
loss of nutrients or the OIC or just
like it's a very stressful time and like
we've got a lot going on and just like
in work in general in my life so um my
doctor says it's stress related but if
it doesn't stop then we have to pursue
something else but got coming out in
clumps like while I'm in the shower it's
not fun I'm so sorry to hear that I find
like hair loss is so traumatic any I'm
also going through a little bit of hair
loss because my ADHD meds and it's it's
it's really tough I'm sure on on men too
but like especially for us women for
whom like you know our hair means a lot
to us um so that's really that's that
sucks um yeah and I don't have a lot of
hair to begin with so oh yeah I mean St
with me my hair is very fine so like to
lose any I'm like no I I let that grow
now just for anyone who is watching or
taking OIC or considering taking OIC
hair loss isn't considered a common side
effect but it does seem to happen around
5% of patients using glp1 agonists and
experts think that the hair loss is
related to something called telen effu
VM uh they don't actually think it's the
medication itself but rather the
hormonal changes and the metabolic
stress on the body that usually is
coming from rapid weight loss so usually
this starts about a few months into
treatment and can usually reverse over
six to 12 months once your weight loss
has stabilized but this is really why
nutrition is so important so you know
maybe taking a multivitamin would be a
good idea here plus of course focusing
on protein throughout the day seeing as
our hair is built on protein so that's
something to think about really for
anyone on
OIC duh duh we
know yeah exactly I have no
idea but speaking of protein and
vitamins you made me look at some of
your wet ien a day videos so I feel like
we're gonna just wash them together and
I'm going to give you my honest thoughts
are you ready Ginger let's do it let's
do it so I start my day with a cup of
espresso coffee as we can see here
followed by a single egg with some salt
and pepper and I finished this off with
um some toast some Earth Balance and a
piece of guda cheese and wow this was
delicious all pre 8:30 for lunch I had a
beef B gigy with some carrots kimchi and
rice I have that so that was my portion
then I had a piece of chocolate about
this size two pieces actually and a
chicken vit a bowl for dinner okay
Ginger everything there looked so
delicious that chocolate bar I don't
know what that is but I want it um and
based on my rough calculations I counted
about 1100 calories um which you know
for most people might be a pretty
aggressive calorie deficit and I'm not
sure what your BMR is because again I'm
not your dietitian but if you are losing
your weight at a reasonable pace of a
pound a week this might be the right
amount of calories for you at this time
that said not enough protein Ginger not
enough protein we need to get that
protein up I think I counted like 50 gr
of protein in the day which is about 20%
of your total calories coming from
protein and I went to a lot more detail
in this on my video for macro ranges but
we need a ton of protein when we're in a
calorie deficit basically the greater
the calorie defs it the more protein we
need and this is basically just help
prevent muscle wasting which is one of
the main major concerns when it comes to
glp1 agonists like OIC so we generally
recommend like 1.8 g of protein per
kilogram of body weight or around 30% of
your total calorie should be coming from
protein but you're only eating like
roughly 1,000 calories so 1.8 gr per
kilogram would be very difficult unless
you're just just eating protein um but
even if we work off of the 30% goal that
would be around 85 G so almost double
what you're consuming currently and I
really think that that breakfast meal
would be the best meal to try to bump
this up right um one egg has only like s
g of protein and we ideally want to get
that up to like 20 to 30 G per meal so
that could mean doing one whole egg plus
a few egg whites in there um a protein
shake Greek yogurt cottage cheese would
be a really great way to start the day
those would be some of my kind of more
high uh protein options for breakfast
also Ginger where's the fruit and
vegetables in the meals yes girl
barely not much not much right so
obviously it's not realistic to get your
full five 10 servings of fruits and
vegetables on a very low calorie diet
like this but I counted maybe a/4 cup of
carrots and a few kernels of corn um and
then the rest of your carbs are
basically coming from lower fiber
options like white bread uh white white
rice and then of course chocolate which
we love of course we have to make space
for the chocolate um but the
recommendation when it comes to fiber is
about 28 gr for women you're getting
five so I only counted five gram of
fiber in this day and again I think it's
really hard to get a full 30 G of fiber
when you're only consuming 1,00 calories
but we could do some super super simple
swaps here just to bump that up a little
bit so you know instead of the white
rice or or you know whatever your your
typical grains are we could do higher
fiber green like a chickpea pasta or
quinoa which would actually double as
protein and the fiber so it does a
little double duty there to bump that up
as well um and I always tell people
don't count calories count colors so I
want you to think about trying to get in
three different colors in your day this
is a really great tip for anybody
watching so three colors could mean
berries at breakfast you could do some
greens with your lunch and like bell
peppers at dinner time and that way
you're going to get a variety of
different fiber sources plus more
antioxidants and if it still is very
difficult for you to meet your fiber
needs I maybe would consider you know
adding a Prebiotic fiber supplement in
there and taking it close to bed so that
it doesn't affect your hunger uh levels
throughout the day you don't want it to
like further affect your appetite and
you not want to get enough calories in
or enough protein in so that's when I
would do it right before bed so what
would happen if I took it earlier in the
day you you can but you just have to
monitor your appetite because you know
fiber makes you feel full and I wouldn't
want to be compromising on you know
antioxidant rich foods or protein rich
foods because you're just feeling full
because you're on OIC and you're now
taking a fiber supplement you're feeling
extra full and therefore you may not be
able to get the actual bare nutrients
that you need to thrive right we were
talking about the hair loss we we still
need nutrients I see I didn't I didn't
know any yeah yeah the things I'm
learning out thanks for learning okay
let's learn some more we're going to
watch another one of your your wedding a
days started the day with my espresso
coffee then I had a protein shake then I
had a pork Teriyaki Bowl which I haveed
and added some soy sauce which was
delicious then my stello two pieces of
licorice okay who making I actually had
four then I had some snap peas and
hummus and finish the day off with some
pasta and sausage and this piece of
delicious chocolate
yum okay so the calories on this day
were slightly lower which I don't love
about 1 th000 calories uh cuz again we
don't want to risk muscle mass loss but
the nutrients and macros we actually did
a lot better on so almost hit that 30%
of calories from protein Mark uh you ate
70 gr protein as opposed to like 50 in
the other day and there was 12 G of
fiber this time so definitely huge
progress here I really think that having
that protein shake in the morning was
you're saving greas because at least
then you're getting a full serving of
protein right in right first thing in
the morning right did it with the snap
piece for a little more fiber uh that
was a really great snack just to sneak
in some extra More Produce and get a
little bit of some color in there um but
again I probably would try to swap in
higher fiber grains or chickpea pasta as
opposed to Rice I might put some fiber
rich berries or greens in the protein
smoothie at breakfast um and if you're
feeling snacky I love me licorice but
maybe do like half Licorice and half
turkey jerky or do a bowl of cottage
cheese with some of the chocolate
shredded on top cuz that way you still
get the protein in those snacks you know
what yeah like you guys you know I'm all
about adding not restricting add don't
restrict and I want to make sure you
still have your fun Foods in the day but
ultimately when your appetite is so
limited your your caloric intake is so
limited you still have to make a bit
more of an effort to meet your basic
nutrient needs so yeah the protein does
need to be number one okay noted so in
terms of the turkey jerky like if I were
to incorporate that or like a pepperette
yeah like I always assumed those were
just like super high in fat so and they
probably it depends on the brand it
depends on the brand yeah um so
definitely compare packages um the
states have a lot more options but you
know compare packages look for a low
lower sodium look for a lower um uh fat
options especially like a a turkey over
a pork or a beef um there are now a lot
more uh nutritious jerky based products
yeah I love that stuff I know I know
it's a good it's a good way to switch it
up if you want like a little salty with
a little sweet okay so big picture here
folks big picture Ginger I want you to
focus on protein at every meal and snack
and to get in some fruits and vegetables
so if you can just focus on those two
things I really think that the rest will
work itself out which is really the perk
of OIC so how do we feel about that love
it love it I love these little tips
these little tips are great amazing
amazing yeah I also want to talk about
the holidays here because I keep seeing
headlines being like it's OIC ruining
Christmas because people are used to the
holiday being this like binge Fest for
everyone this like Collective binge and
some people are just worried that it
feels less festive when you don't Gorge
yourself so I'm I'm just curious like
you know having gone through the
holidays now did anyone give you a hard
time for not eating as much as you used
to or as what everybody else is eating
like how did that go gosh no number one
I'm so open about this so you know if
somebody has a problem they're not
telling me to my face but okay it's not
really it's not not a me problem it's a
you problem if it's a problem for you at
all so you know what I mean oh for sure
no listen I'm still enjoying everything
that I want to eat the only things that
I'm really having a hard time with that
I have to be like really mindful is any
of those fried foods they just don't sit
well in my stomach but I'm having the
turkey I'm having the stuffing I'm
having a little bit of the gravy I'm
having the mashed potatoes I'm having
the pumpkin pie like I'm I'm doing it
all I'm just not doing a huge portion Y
and if I feel full and I'm starting to
feel full I'm walking away I I love that
and that's that's the way it should be
right like you are just listening to
your body and and you've now realized
that some of these like very very fatty
foods perhaps don't sit as well so like
turkey would be a better option than
like a very very well marbled prime rib
for example and so you make those
choices accordingly and what feels good
to your body and and that's kind of one
of the big perks of oen piic is
basically relearning your body's cues
and needs so I think that's really
really great um but I have another
question about the holidays because one
of the the big side effects that we hear
from a lot of OIC users is that they
generally don't feel like drinking as
much or at all um what's been your
experience with alcohol and OIC I used
to love winding down with a glass of
wine sitting by the fireplace you know
maybe watching a television show or
actually let's be honest I watch the
news like 247 but
depressing it's not really been wind
down material lately so um so no so but
I just haven't had that craving I I find
like I'm having a glass of water instead
um but if I'm with my family or my
friends I'm definitely having a cocktail
than a glass of wine or two um so I I'm
not not drinking but I'm only drinking
in social situations like I'm not having
anything on my own and I'm popped out at
two really yep I think that's excellent
I mean we've we've talked on my channel
most recently about um alcohol and the
effect on weight loss and weight gain
and I think that yeah that that two
drink Mark is is really great place to
to be in to stop so I'm glad that that's
feeling more intuitive for you you as
well so that's fantastic um but we
mentioned earlier OIC shortages yeah so
like Novo nordis who is the maker of OIC
have been warning that they are
expecting that there's going to be these
worldwide shortages that are going to be
continuing into the first quarter of
2024 and then after that well who really
knows what's going to happen so what is
your plan so when they increased my dose
to the 2 milligrams that's when they
were starting to talk about the shortage
coming to Canada originally we were
actually in a good place uh the US had
major shortages but Canada was going to
be fine um and it was I think October
shortage and I had to call around
different pharmacies to try and see who
had it because I hadn't really spoken to
my doctor yet about when the shortage
happens what do I do um so I found a
pharmacy and then they then they had the
shortage so my doctor and I um talked
about different solutions so saxenda was
a solution but that's lorag glutide I
had previously tried seenda in my
younger years um it's a daily injection
um it just didn't work for me I think it
was the daily in injection like I just
mentally couldn't do it and hadn't gone
through the egg freezing at that point
so didn't know what it was like to give
myself three or four needles a day yeah
uh now I'm fine one a week is nothing um
so but what we ended up where we landed
was rebellis so rebellis is the oral
it's the same drug so it's smuti um but
it's a daily pill you have to fast for a
little bit after taking it in order for
your body to absorb it so it's kind of
like just wrapping my head around um how
that was going to work okay my doctor
prescribed that sent it to my Pharmacy
and my pharmacist actually called me and
in the craziest shocker they had 1
milligram pens so they called me and
they were like let's keep you on OIC
because we've got them in stock however
my dad had just told me that he couldn't
get the OIC my dad is diabetic has had a
heart attack and is on OIC for diabetes
smaller dose than what I'm on now cuz
I'm on the kind of the therapeutic
weight loss dose so I I'm like can
instead of me can my dad can I get it
for my dad she's like yep we have some
in stock like no problem so we actually
transferred his prescription over um to
get the 1 milligram yeah so so you
really it's about calling around in
Canada and some are getting the 0. five
some are getting the one it makes zero
sense it is not practical
um but rebellis seems to be a good
option um and there's no shortage of
ralis so oh well that's great yeah it is
an oral medication no needles at least
for those who are freaked out about
needles it's slightly less effective
than OIC especially because the max dose
is equivalent to basically like half of
what you're used to taking it's
equivalent to 1 milligram of ozempic but
who knows you know if if you end up
going that route and and you need to
stay on that for a while it might even
be kind of better for you it's it's it's
something that you can you can test out
and see and then hopefully uh you can
get back to whatever method works best
for you shortly after once they figure
the demand is clearly not going away and
so yeah they'll just have to ramp up
production I guess so yeah it's
definitely not going away now that Oprah
came out and fully admitted that she's
taking a weight loss drug as well which
you know I was kind of like yes Oprah
like I was like finally you know um
because you know what she said in that
interview was this is the tool that I
needed to stop yo-yo diving and that's
how I felt my whole life like I've just
been up and down and up and down and up
and down and it has never been healthy
right and it has never been fun and um I
just you know what if that's if this is
the drug that some people who don't have
that hunger Q need in order to avoid
diabetes and heart issues and the other
things that our medical system you know
gets pressured and you know that that's
put on the medical system and this helps
curb that y Bring It On yeah and you
know again this is part of the reason
why we're doing this series is we want
to uh remove the stigma away from folks
who are just getting the health care
that they need um you know no different
than getting chemo for cancer um or you
know get taking steroids for um IB IBD
you know or mental health medication
like we like you know I do um we really
want to help folks feel like they don't
need to have any more shame or feel any
more judged than they already have in
their life for just being you know in a
larger body so I think this is great and
of course somebody like Oprah is got
such clout such presence so um you know
I I hope her her her giving her blessing
is enough to help encourage others to to
you know no longer be judging those who
are seeing this as the easy way out as
we've said if I may on easy way out it's
not easy no because you know you have to
learn how to consume properly or else
you will not feel good and I'm also I
mean I'm doing a pretty active effort at
the fitness portion of it too like
trying to balance it with Fitness but it
is not easy and what what I hope doesn't
happen with Oprah coming out because
Oprah does have an investment in Weight
Watchers which we need
and which we don't Weight Weight
Watchers was was just a mind to me
anyways but you and many others yes you
know but but Weight Watcher has invested
in the company that now prescribes
weight loss medication so obviously it's
her her best interest to promote it and
to talk about it from a financial
perspective but I also believe that in
the long run if this this could if this
is a life-changing drug it will help
like it'll just
be super impactful for everyone M
exactly y so I'm super excited to check
in with you again and maybe another
month or so um and I hope that you know
I hope that the new drug works out for
you and we can kind of continue on this
journey and you're feeling good about it
no new side effects H you know I know
that anytime you switch a drug it can be
a little bit um of a challenge there
might be some hiccups along the way
along the way but hopefully it's a
smooth transition and we can check in
with you in a few months everybody
please leave us some really nice
supportive comments uh down below we all
know that sharing these stories are not
easy especially in this world where
there is so much judgment for any choice
a woman makes for her own body so let's
try to keep it supportive and kind here
in the comments and thank you Ginger
again for for sharing your story thanks
Abby awesome and don't forget to hit
that subscribe button if you are not
already and I will see you next time on
aby's kitchen bye
a